how can we understand this i think
governor newsom said it best what the
hell is wrong with us
america and that's where we begin as we
welcome you to cbs this morning it's a
terrible story where the flags are at
half staff at the white house this
morning
after yet another horrific mass shooting
in this country we don't yet know why a
transit employee
opened fire at a rail yard yesterday in
san jose
we do know that he killed at least nine
of his co-workers and that several
others were wounded here
this is the shooter he is 57 year old
sam cassidy
his ex-wife says that he had a temper
police say
that he killed himself as they rushed in
jamie yukas is in san jose with more on
the story
jamie there have been at least 62 mass
shootings in this country in the month
what do we know about the victims in
this particular tragedy
well gail many of the victims were
long-time employees of the transit
agency including one who started
in 1999 they were bus and light rail
operators mechanics lineman and a
manager
for more than a year these employees
worked through the dangers of the
pandemic
only now to fall victim to a mass
shooting
family members at this reunification
site wailed
after waiting nearly 12 hours only to
learn
their loved ones were among those killed
in wednesday's shooting
we lose the good person he's the very
good person in our family
tupted's jeep singh was one of those
killed he worked as a light rail
operator for roughly nine years
and leaves behind a wife and two small
children
co-workers told his family the
36-year-old pushed one of them into a
room to hide from the shooter
then frantically started warning others
he just saved her and
after that he go towards the downstairs
you know shots rang out at the valley
transportation authority at around 6 30
in the morning wednesday as workers were
changing shifts
trains
a law enforcement source tells cbs news
workers had gathered for a union meeting
when the shooting started
they were heard yelling run hide fight
officers were on scene almost
immediately they entered the building
and encountered the alleged shooter sam
cassidy
who took his own life glenn hendricks is
chair of valley transportation authority
never in my wildest dreams did i ever
think something like this would occur
cassidy a 57-year-old transit employee
lived nearby
a neighbor's doorbell camera shows him
leaving the house wednesday morning
with a large black duffel bag
[Applause]
shortly before he allegedly began
shooting a fire erupted at his home
police suspect arson and later found
hundreds of rounds of ammunition inside
cassidy's ex-wife cecilia nelms says he
struggled with a temper
that was one of our biggest problems
he was very quiet he thinks of himself
the violence waged here now representing
the seventh workplace shooting
this year when they said goodbye to
their
their spouse this morning their husband
they didn't mean goodbye forever
they meant goodbye until dinnertime
and that's the toughest part adrian
baeza was another victim in the shooting
his wife tells us she's heartbroken her
two-year-old son
will have to grow up without his father
she says baeza couldn't wait until their
son was old enough to take him fishing
and now she's devastated he won't get to
watch him grow up
authorities have not said what the
motive behind this was they also did not
say what type of weapon was used
or if the suspect got the weapon legally
anthony
our condolences to those families in san
jose jamie thank you